now to a fierce diplomatic row within
the western alliance and france has
recalled its ambassadors to the united
states and australia that's after
canberra scrapped a major french
submarine purchase in favor of
nuclear-powered subs built with u.s
technology foreign minister jean-yves
leduron said the cancellation of the
contract was quote unacceptable behavior
between allies and partners
on wednesday u.s president joe biden
infuriated paris by announcing a new
indo-pacific security alliance with
australia and britain france is set to
lose 31 billion euros on the submarines
and says it expects compensation
dw correspondents on ifanika is in paris
sonia france first described this pack
as a stab in the back now it's recalling
its ambassadors why is the macron
administration so angry
well rebecca i think a key reason for
the french anger is the way that this um
deal between australia the us and the uk
has been announced now officials here in
paris say that they were really not
informed about this deal until a few
hours before it was announced and they
also say it was a complete surprise
because um they had no idea that it was
part of a new security alliance
involving three countries including the
uk um and this is seen here as
undercutting france's own indo-pacific
strategy um french officials also say
this is very much at odds with what
australian officials had been saying to
france until about two weeks ago you
know essentially re-confirming the
submarine deal so i think france is
really there's a lot of shock here it's
really been blindsided by this
announcement
where does this leave france's presence
in the asia pacific region and it's the
only eu nation with territories there
you're right i mean uh france is is the
only european power to have a presence
in the indo-pacific you know it still
has considerable territory up to up to
two million um citizens uh it has a
strong military presence in a vast
maritime stretch of the south pacific
and analysts here are saying that this
really does raise questions about its
relationship with us with australia
which has been an ally in the
indo-pacific you know this submarine
deal was seen as a kind of a centerpiece
of rejuvenation of ties between paris
and canberra um and now the scuppering
of this deal they say you know
potentially could raise questions about
a rupture between between australia and
france yeah well i wanted to ask you a
little bit more about that i mean how
much damage has the loss of this big
submarine contract with australia done
to the french defense industry
well i think the the the scuppering of
this deal has certainly meant a huge
economic damage for the the france's
defense sector and it has also meant a
lot of losses for a vast network of of
small and medium-sized companies in
france now back in 2016 australia signed
the submarine deal um for for a price
tag of about 31 billion uh dollars um
that that that was huge uh france uh
committed to you know um providing 12
conventional submarines and the french
media have been saying that about 500
people have been working on building
those submarines in a town in normandy
and of course the fear now here is that
those jobs uh may well be lost and and
diplomatically of course this is not
good news for um french president
emmanuel macron who faces you know
re-election in in just about seven
months and so this certainly raises the
political stakes for him as well yeah
indeed sonia fanuca speaking to us from
paris thanks very much
you